notre acte avec la plus haute
vague
sony tu peux laisser une note oui c'est
énorme ce qu'il fasse et ses deux frères
à moi qui s'occupe d'eux mais en plus
c'est pas vrai ah ouais t'as des frères
poret 2,8 millions d'abonnés sur un star
oui voilà c'est youtube sa chaîne c'est
un truc c'est un carton de fou je viens
avec son clip mini mini j'ai vu des
milliers de fois bossi il a été vu 60
millions vu avec gc c'est quand même
beaucoup et j'ai pas compris en vrai
pour moi j'ai compris mes appareils
épinac inox tag tout va bien mais tu es
fou quoi enfin bien sûr garde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des garçons voilà qu on adore atone il
est très fort j'entrais un énorme carton
je vous le dis une obstacle c'est un
énorme carton voilà il fait partie de la
team croûtons qu'on embrasse on embrasse
la brasse messieurs the tout ça voilà le
alors là
là là autour de la table actionnaires ce
qui se posent
ou vide auquel
non mais sans déconner j'ai décroché
pernikoff tu comprends ce qu'on veut
dire le comprendrai jamais pourquoi lui
c'est vrai einstein tu t'intéresses à
lui même et en font la figure quand même
avec cette voie comme ça
avec ta tête et e
je m'intéresse beaucoup à lui ça peut
être très belle interview j'ai déjà
twitter
[Applaudissements]
je lui fais gaffe inox suis très content
de martelly il est fils unique tu m'as
dit ouais aime et on perd comme un papa
lé là à la télé les riads embrasse son
papa elle s'appelle comment kader kader
dans leurs bras ce cas des ronds lembras
traitement normalement parce que
normalement de son père normand il doit
s'appeler kevin ce que son père jay
explique-t-il à 26 ans
bien c'est vrai les pourriels à rien
sans déconner oui c'est vrai il ya cash
qu'on perd
3,47 points car nous
voulons la cgem
bah écoute et est une cousine n'y paraît
ouais c'est son anniversaire non madame
on l'appelle bon anniversaire ça mal
comment il souhaitait cyrielle affairés
à l'incroyable uriage je me suis arrivé
est accoudé
au bar manche la cenco mouais pas si les
50 piges
qui les prix on dit quoi il est brillant
tout parce qu'en plus il a eu son bac
oui oui avec mon chien c'est parce qu'il
a 19 ans mais ouais c'est vrai que
j'avais des facultés et les facilités à
l'école alors et facilite à l'école sa
valise un chasseur
je n'avais pas besoin forcément beaucoup
travaillé j'écoute en classe et sa web
tonneau que tu as fait quoi toi tu
arrêter l'école auquel à des fous j'ai
passé mon bac j'ai déjà mon père merci
non c'est la source
j'ai perdu cet hiver j'ai mais voilà mon
père m'a toujours
chaude écoute et tomba qui après je fais
ce que tu veux c'est ca batna fait de
victime avec la commande au père de
castanet aussi lui a dit et on pas
qu'après tout ouvrir les yeux
il a adapté son bac
alors ils notent sydom sortir à nouveau
son chaque sont chacun de ces sons
cartonne pas besoin de toi je pense
qu'il parle de vous
j'ai sorti samedi il est déjà numéro 5
des tendances il cumule plus de trois
millions quatre jours plus tard ils ont
vu en quatre jours est hélas est à noter
un fossé c'est grâce à eux je sème aussi
d'ailleurs j'embrasse la communauté
chana tova
tobar que sa mère alors on va voir est
ce qu'on l'a le clip parce qu'on a des
problèmes de magnéto monts au locle
c'est le seul truc qu'on a réussi à
sauver son magnéto ce soir parce que
sinon on n'avait rien dit
[Musique]
un casse et de la mobilité
la
casse et des lobbies
toi je suis pas toi andriuzzi pas besoin
de toi tu viens j'ai pas besoin de toi
pas besoin de toi et toi ça j'ai pas
besoin de toi sous l'eau
la banquette
[Applaudissements]
et knox a besoin de toi je comprends
moi aussi j'ai dans l'idée reste seul
face à moi-même alone on l'est pour 4 tu
vas pas me faire un duo avec une grande
star de la télé
soit pas ici
je parle de fois où ses mixes et qui
s'est mis non monsieur je suis trop
jeune
[Applaudissements]
la mode connais la part si tu toi tu
tiens point soleil ce qui s'est
passé c'est non c'est non et lui tu sais
qui c'est lui oui je vous ai déjà vu je
sais pas
a lâché un jeune non nettoyés les
personnes est-ce que tu connais au moins
la personne au bout la balade la jeune
fille non désolé je connais personne en
fait c'est vraiment pas tony mais
écouter mais je mets jaune est ce normal
c'est même moi
[Rires]
je n'ai pas tout monsieur là je ne sais
pas qui sont ces gens